You are listening to
radiolab radio from W N Y.
S. T. E. N. N. P. R. Hey.
Hi. How are you? I'm fine.
How are you Robert? Nice to speak
to you after all these years. Yes,
it's been quite a few years.
I should let you know the Jad Abumrad
has just wandered in. Hello. Hi Jad,
this is Adrian Noey.
Last name is N. O. E. N.
I'm director of the National
Museum of Health and medicine.
So you know why we're calling
you, right? Yes. Okay.
So what's the spring
it on the audience? Um,
I don't remember how I
happen to bump into you.
I don't even know how this came up.
I think you and I had, um,
been coke presenters at a ted
conference probably a decade ago.
We may have been talking about, um,
important events in New York
or civic architecture, but I,
but I do remember perking
up at the phrase grants too.
So Robert said something to
you about grants tomb. Yes.
And then you turned to be, say it again.
Now you may know who's
buried in grant's tomb,
but I know it's buried in grant's tumor.
Yes. He turns it out at the
museum. She works at, there is a
tumor that had been excised from the
throat of president grant in the 1880s
actual tissue from grant's tumor. Yes,
that's right.
Yes. Here we are,
the National Museum of Health
and medicine in Gladesville name.
It is kept behind several locked doors,
so you guys don't have an inkling of what
you're about to see if we go in there
now, but it's a privileged
area. This is Brian's Spatola.
He's the collections manager and he let
us down a long hallway to some doors and
took me back. Oh, holy moly. Oh my God.
There's like other twin babies
and in Formaldehyde look,
Greens heads torsos and majority
even gotten to the tumors.
Right. So he let us out of that
room and into another one in the,
you're sitting on a table and
waiting for us is this, is this,
the thing about which we spoke it is was
President Ulysses Simpson grants tumor.
Oh Wow.
Lots of it was resting in a
box that looked as it happen
and it's exactly like a
cigar box. Oh. Which is a little ironic.
This was the guy who never ever
stopped having a cigar in his mouth.
He never stopped having cigars.
He smoked as many as 12 cigars a day. Wow.
So it was probably the
cigars that made the tumor
February of 1885 tissue
was removed, examined,
and his physicians, um,
concluded that he had a squamous cell
carcinoma and ultimately he was treated
for pain and died in July
of 85. That same year.
Well, it's pretty fast. So that's
what killed president grant then?
It was a tumor. Yes. I didn't know that.
So you see the staining that they use
to bring out the details in the cells is
the darkness, the tumor, the
darkness is the tumor. Wow.
The very stuff that even though
president grant got through Vicksburg,
I didn't even know he came east and
they fight, tried to kill him here.
They tried to kill him
there. They tried to go.
Then he goes and becomes president.
This is what actually killed him.
This is what kills him.
Wow. Can I touch it? Um,
no,
we may not be able to touch the actual
tumor of the president of the United
States, but we can touch on this
subject. We can grasp this subject.
We can examine this subject coming
up on radio lab for the next hour.
It's totally tumors. Oh,
come on. Don't call that.
Cause really what we're going to talk
about are not just any tumors but famous
tumors, immortal tumors, devil tumors,
he just tumors and tumors that speak up.
[inaudible]
I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm
about to be confused.
The Big One and I'm Jad Abumrad
this is Radiolab. Stay with us.
[inaudible]
wow.
Alright. To get things
to get things rolling.
This first story is about something
that we thought was not possible that we
hoped was not possible.
We learned it from, uh,
I'll make it work from this Guy David
Coleman. I'm a science journalist. He is,
I think my favorite in my generation.
I think he is the best writer
that writes about science.
I specialize in evolutionary biology and
travel on assignment to far away places
and interesting situations.
All right, so first of all,
where are you going to take
us to? What part of the world?
I'm going to take you to
Tasmania,
which is the island state off the
south coast of Australia. You know,
you go to Australia and you think of
Brock and deserts and red dirt and heat,
but you keep going south all
the way off the south coast.
Suddenly you have these
rolling green countrysides,
lots of wallabies,
one of the species of kangaroo that
like bonding them countryside with
wallabies. Is that the, exactly
with small kangaroos hopping around,
but our story does not actually
begin in Tasmania. Nope.
It starts in Holland with a gentleman
by the name of Christo Bosh.
Is that bar as in B a r Bosh?
Christo bars is a wonderfully
independent spirited plumber.
A plumber,
plumber guy do to make a living on the
photographing is for me a big hobby. I,
we don't know just how
great a plumber he is,
but he's a very good wildlife photographer
and he looks for interesting animals
to shoot with the camera.
I mean, so over the years,
often he puts down his
ranch and he travels. Yeah,
well we don't have that many animals
here in Holland. A little bit of Roe,
deer and sometimes a Fox.
And in the early nineties he goes to
take his latest photography sabbatical in
Tasmania. Have I gone to
a attach mania on boat?
And were you there to take pictures of
wallabies or Kangaroos? No, no, no, no.
He was there this time to photograph
devils. Tasmanian devils. Yeah. Oh,
I quite liked the animals. What
is, I mean, I know the cartoon,
but what does a real Tasmanian
Devil acce look like,
whether they're about as
big as a little pit bull,
but look a little bit more like a
bear cub white yoke on its chest.
Big Set of formidable teeth. They'll
eat almost anything. Anything,
anything like Afar Plata, push, kelp,
maggots and fish snakes, garbage cans,
occasional rubber boot,
you name it. Anyway,
when crystal gets to Tasmania,
he drives up the coast.
He finds dead animals on the
road, you know, roadkill,
roadkill from the road to use as bait.
What sort of roadkill? Oh, Kangaroos,
a little devil can eat
a kangaroo. Oh yeah.
When the three four five together to eat
a big kangaroo in an hour is gone. Wow.
So he takes the dead kangaroo,
drags it to clearing in the forest,
sets up his photography equipment, very
close. And then what happens? Well,
you just wait
[inaudible]
so he waited
as the nightfall little black
ships began to creep out of the,
you can hear them sniffing
and refine the roadkill.
Ah,
and then I just started eating and
fighting with each other. [inaudible]
this squad scary. If you don't
know what what you're hearing
as the e Christina,
Danny, at a safe distance,
English shadows takes their plunger.
Okay.
[inaudible]
over the years he's done
this over and over and over,
but he always sees lots of devils.
Devils in front of his lenses.
Sometimes 20 devil's running around,
devil's in his kitchen or come
into your tent. Devil's everywhere.
But after a bunch of
trips, something happened.
It was Easter 1996 he was in the park
watching a dead kangaroo and waiting for
the devils to show. But only
thing I saw was one devil,
just one, eh? [inaudible] I'll try
another spot. I had another spot,
tried it at two devils.
They're not gone entirely,
but they're scarce.
And you notice something strange
about one or two of the devils.
It was something on the face
is fasion on the backend,
on their mouth and something
that looked like a growth,
a large ugly growth
thought. Oh well maybe uh,
they've been bitten, are fighting
with each other and bits troll on up.
But it was really big, you
know, and blood coming out.
And this was the first alarm bell.
So crystal, you were the
first to see it. Yes.
And this was just the beginning.
[inaudible]
like a pie out of hell and dark
death is sweeping Tasmania.
Television reporters got this.
Don't fronted anything like this.
And began reporting that more and more.
Tasmanian devils had these lumps on
their faces. They fill the eye sockets,
they puff out the lips,
they infect the gums.
It's really sad and hideous
and whatever they were,
they turned out to be lethal.
To jump ahead a little bit.
The effect that it's had in
the population, in some cases,
devil populations collapsed
by 90%, died off very quickly.
Scientists looked at the disease and
determined that it was some kind of tumor
cancer, a cancerous tumor. And then
the question was what's causing them?
So what, what, what did they think? Well,
the toxic chemical was guest number one,
some poison or pesticide
from the environment. Yes,
number two was a virus. So they
tested in places where the doubles,
they're looking for something toxic
or some virus and they found nothing.
And then along comes a woman
named Anne Marie Pierce.
She looked at some tumors close up, um,
very close up from 11 different devils.
So she's looking at the first tumor and
she found that the chromosomes were sort
of mangled, which isn't really that
strange because that's what cancer is.
It's like your genetic
stuff gone screwy. Right?
But then she looked at the tumor from
the next note and she found not just also
mangled chromosomes,
but chromosomes that were mangled in
exactly the same way as they had been in
the first devil. Hmm. So now she
looks at a third identical metaphor,
identical and then a
fifth identity. All 11.
Exactly the same pattern
in each [inaudible].
Does that I,
I feel the sensation of awe,
but I don't quite have these
understanding attachment.
Does that mean that that
these tumors are all brothers?
What that meant was that these tumors
were all genetically identical.
They were all the same tumor. How
can they all be the same tumor? Well,
they can't because,
because that wouldn't mean that these
Tasmanian devils caught the cancer from
some other Tasmanian Devil. Exactly.
Wait, what do you mean exactly?
You can't catch cancers.
Epidemic of cancer in Tasmanian devils
was a crazy impossible tumor that was
jumping
[inaudible]
with leaping from one devil to another.
raping tumor. Yeah, a leaping tumor
[inaudible] point in this tale where we
really have to question everything that
we thought. We knew. No cancer.
Now most people think of cancer as like
a situation in which one of your cells
starts replicating and it doesn't stop.
It replicates uncontrollably
until it destroys you.
Okay. So that's like the one cell theory,
which is frankly how I thought cancer
worked. Oh Peter, we have to go ahead.
Just start. But then we spoke with this
fellow. Yup. His name is Carlo Maley,
cancer biologist at the Wistar Institute.
And he told us if you really want to
understand what's happening with the
devils, you're going to toss
out the one cell theory.
Cause cancer is not just not
just a cell going haywire. No,
it's actually many cells
competing, competing for space,
competing for resources and in the
process driving each other haywire.
Like if you were to
somehow go into a tumor,
he says what you would find is between
a billion and a trillion cells in there.
So these are different cells,
this huge clump of cells in there.
They're all fighting it out.
Cause you know space is tight,
food is scarce.
And what'll happen is in the middle
of this melee and you as the sales are
competing each individual
sellers trying to copy itself,
copy, copy Gabby. And somewhere
along the way you get eventually
a copying error. And every so often
says, Carla, one of these mistakes,
we'll give the new sale a new
talent. In the case of cancer,
it usually starts with
something pretty simple,
like the ability to slurp up food,
Fester nutrients like oxygen and
glucose. Now with this advantage,
that mutant and all of its progeny
will take over that area of the tissue,
but
not for long because now you've got
all these beauties and they start to
randomly again, you get
another copy of the state
and maybe this second copying mistake
gives the cell the ability to divide
faster, right?
So there it is proliferating faster than
its neighbors and it takes over growing
and displacing the other cells. But yeah,
it just keeps getting worse because
now you've got these double meals.
They can eat fast, they
can divide quickly,
and they start to fight until you
get a third mutation, then a fourth,
and you just keep ratcheting it up and
eventually roughly five to 20 mutations,
you end up with a cell that
is so gnarled, so mutated,
and so powerful that it can
literally spit a kind of acid
called a matrix metallo protease that
allows it to rip through the membrane
barriers, and
this is when you're really in
trouble because now the cell can roam
and so the cells leave the primary tumor,
they've got dissolved their way into
a blood vessel. That's a mutation.
Then they've got to survive and
the blood, another mutation,
then they've got to stick
somewhere else yet another.
Then they've got to dissolve back
through the RTL adding in another. Yeah,
so it sounds like cancer is always
evolving to be more cancerous. It totally,
yes.
This also explains why we
haven't been able to cure it.
Why when a person takes
chemotherapy drugs, the cancer
will go away for a while,
but then it'll come back
stronger cause the cells have
evolved a resistance to those drugs.
When I first got into work on cancer,
I was impressed at how malevolent the
disease seems as if it's being designed to
kill us. So here's my question. Um,
this leaping tumor in
the devils [inaudible],
is this a case where the tumor is actually
evolving into a new form like after,
say the 50th mutation or whatever?
Like now it doesn't just have
the ability to travel in a body,
but it can somehow leap out
of a body through the air
and into another body? Sure.
I mean, the only, that's really
scary. Yes it is. It is pretty scary.
But, but this is amazingly rare
and according to Carlo demand,
some pretty special circumstances. Oh,
would m a Tasmanian devil would some
tumor get from one individual to another?
What would, well, how would that
happen? Tasmanian devils. God bless him,
bite one another in the face a lot.
They're scrambling over carcasses.
They're fighting and biting,
swallowing, crunching,
and the males also bite females
during the meeting period.
He's
a little bit of a rough lover.
So you have the male and the female
biting each other in the face. So, uh,
devil with a tumor on its face,
let's say it's mating with another devil
and it bites that second devil in the
face. What exactly happens at that
point? Is it just rubbing its tumor?
When you think of these big ugly
tumors, think of fetter cheese.
And when one devil bites another,
there's a tendency for the tumor to
crumble and to shed tumor cells that then
fall into the wounds on
the second devil. But um,
some of you I don't understand. Um,
why wouldn't the immune system of the
devil's kill those cells prevent those
cells from taking root? Yeah. Cause
that's what immune systems do.
And the latest answer is that, well,
Tasmanian devils don't have as much
genetic diversity as you would expect.
Whether that means David explained to us
is that the Tasmanian devil population
has gotten so inbred,
they are so alike at a genetic level
that their immune systems now confused.
They don't know the difference between
their own cells and invading cells coming
in from other devils. Exactly.
Which doesn't actually sound like
the tumor is all that powerful.
So I asked Carlo Maley,
you get a mutation.
That's really the story
of a tumor evolving,
more adaptive or is it just the story
of a tumor getting lucky them those.
I think those are the same
story. How do you mean?
I mean evolution is all about dumb luck.
The way he explained it,
it's dumb luck that the tumor
was on the outside of the face.
It's dumb luck that they
bite each other a lot.
That a cell could come along that
could shed and fall into a wound.
It's all dumb luck. But that he
says is what makes evolution happen.
That's natural selection right
there. And when you step back,
sometimes the results are just
nuts. Yeah, just nuts.
This is the point. Yeah.
Where we need to talk about a
transmissible tumor in, in dogs,
canine transmissible venereal tumor.
This is a tumor.
He says it's evolved way beyond the
one in the devils and way longer.
How long is that
Donna? Well,
it's been going on for
somewhere between 220 500 years.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Between 220 500 years.
Yeah. Yes. Unit. Yes. Over
to millennia. Exactly.
And if that's the case,
then it's the oldest continuous animals
cell line in existence on planet earth.
You might need to say that again
because that is just too strange.
It is. It is. Even stranger,
it says David [inaudible].
When a tumor lives this long
propagates itself this long,
you can only really call it one thing.
This tumor is essentially an animal,
a parasite, not a species of parasite,
but one individual parasite
that may never die.
[inaudible]
David Corbin is the other
sauna at the Dodo natural acts.